Well, you see, I received a phone call.
And I was working with about half a dozen other people at the time.
And I couldn't believe what I heard. I was sort of,...
...it was terribly exciting but I just had to carry on working...
...and pretending that everything was normal, when of course I was thinking about,...
...I just was overwhelmed, privileged, excited and daunted all at the same time.
I do know that they love our fruit cake...
...and we are making a traditional fruit cake...
...which is actually how I started the business. So, we know how to do that well.
We have quite a sort of a modern style of cake decorating but it's quite traditional as well,...
...and quite delicate.
And we do make a lot of flowers and I think they just liked our style.
We are making a recipe which is a very traditional recipe...
...and it's just slightly changed for them.
It's just the most exciting cake.
We all do feel very privileged, we're all very excited about making the cake.